[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
andrew marchand has been a busy man the
new york post senior sports media
columnist and host of
and iran the sports media podcast and of
course andrew had the news about tom
brady going to fox signing that 10-year
deal andrew explain the timing of this
of brady signing this deal
well they're signing him
with the idea that he's one day going to
retire you know when that is we don't
know obviously brie uh has been uh
something that we kind of haven't seen
the nfl
before he's going to be 45
to start next season and so uh this is
for when he retires
that's when the deal
will kick in
in terms of the timing of the deal uh
when he first announced he'd retired uh
the fox did reach out to him and uh his
agent did express that tom had some um
interest and then you know and i had
that on my radar but then when he went
back to play it kind of went off the
radar and then yesterday that was why we
got the surprise announcement okay was
this did brady
approach fox or vice versa
it's one of those things you know tom
brady and peyton manning are kind of in
their own class when you talk about uh
people wanting them on tv uh so uh i
just think it's kind of an assumption
that fox would want to talk to tom brady
right like if tom brady comes out
everybody's gonna want to talk to him
he's considered the greatest quarterback
of all time he has the personality he
kind of fits everything to a t uh so you
know who made the first call i'd imagine
it was probably fox and then uh you know
brady said yeah i got a little interest
and the mother ship jumped in they uh
did did brady leverage this or his agent
to say
i'm i'm open for business here
yeah so you know the one other place i
do know that you know had talks with
brady uh was the espn um but you know
they already have their full share of
quarterbacks to call games and you know
they have joe buck now and troy aikman
every week on monday night starting this
season and then the manning cast last
year with peyton uh so i think if he had
done espn it'd be more of like espn play
uh streaming you know doing production
stuff and then maybe uh some pre-game
shows would have maybe been a
possibility but you know the games is
really where the big big money is
located although you know i think espn
disney would have you know
the idea is to be in business with tom
brady for a long time and i think they
would have been they were interested uh
not the level of 375 million dollar
level that fox went to see i thought
that this is where amazon would jump in
because they got the deepest pockets and
if you want to make a splash
you can make a splash with tom brady not
that kirk kerb street is not going to be
a complimentary partner with al michaels
throw tom brady in the mix you're going
to get people's attention
well if he had stayed retired dan it's
interesting you said i haven't mentioned
this in any articles but if you had
stayed retired
you got to think that amazon might have
gone
even higher right like what would amazon
had paid uh to team brady with al
michaels and to really make that super
splash um and then you know there's
other things that come along with tom
brady right he has all these companies
uh and so there are big deals to be made
and i think when you look at even the
fox deal um we don't know how it's all
broken down exactly we just know the
number uh and so yes it's for analyzing
games they talked about the brand
ambassador um you know there's some
ideas i have that you know i don't know
foley's i don't want to speculate on
terms of things he might do uh but but
it's more encompassing so yeah amazon
did make a lot of sense the problem with
amazon i even thought about it after is
that you can't really hire him like
foxes right fox is hiring him to uh
to call games eventually amazon starts
its first year next year and yeah you
could hire somebody else but it's like
al michaels and just somebody else who's
holding the place for tom brady i don't
know i don't think that can really work
i think fox is going to get a bargain
out of this
you know it's funny you say that yeah i
think when you look at the history
it could almost in sports you know like
like i'm gonna take it off the media
like look what the mets are doing right
with steve cohen he's investing
investing investing when steinberger
came into the yankees invest
investigation when you are betting on
good products like the nfl
i'm not saying you can't there's not
there's no money that that you could
spend that'd be too much but when you
think about it
you know who knows that tom brady will
fulfill this whole 10-year contract
right he's got a lot of interest maybe
ownership there's a lot of things that
could happen over 10 years but let's
just say you have a relationship with
tom brady for 10 years the greatest of
all time and let's say he's okay as a
broadcaster he's doing other things
the way the business is going i i you
might be right like this might be just a
really good deal especially if
he's into it um and and you know we know
brady enough to think that um he's not
going to do something where he's not
going to be all in kind of like peyton
uh you know with uh
with what he's doing with omaha
productions you know peyton's all in
like he's working on that he's not just
a figurehead
and i think brady's similar of course
and i think he'll work at this now will
he be good that's another question i
think he has potential well that i was
going to ask you that
it's one of those obvious questions like
is brady gonna be any good as an analyst
i mean these things it's impossible to
totally predict i think i think
personally i would say i bet more that
he will be good um i think when you look
at what
you know if you have the right partner
and you've hit on this a number of times
like and you know this from your
experience it's the play-by-play guy
that really makes the analyst not that
there are analysts who will be good um
despite a play-by-play guy but there's
the analyst i mean the play by play guys
really so having kevin burkhart who is
an all-around great guy like everyone
loves kevin burkhart um
it's gonna i think help him he's gonna
try to he's a good teammate he's gonna
try to make tom brady successful and i
think that's really important uh for
brady uh but at the end of the day like
people always get into will he
criticized right and it's always a
misnomer right he doesn't have to go on
the air and just kill people to be good
that's not what it is and it's it's
telling us things we don't know things
we don't see and when you watch the
manning cast to me like what really
separates is peyton's mind is this
working at a higher level right he's the
you know he's arguably you know along
with brady the greatest quarterback of
all time and just the things that he
points out you don't hear that in
regular broadcasts and obviously the
form is easier to do that but you
imagine brady especially when he's just
going to be right off the field is going
to see things in defenses point out
little things that the average person
the average quarterback doesn't see and
that's where i think he could kind of
separate himself and be really good on
the air and the idea that you come on
with tom brady does give it a little bit
more prominence now what's that worth
overall that we could argue all day
about that but it does give it a bigger
feel if you have tom brady involved in
your broadcast i mentioned this the
first hour that i would have the tomcam
and i would have the camera behind the
quarterback and tom is
the quarterback he's the camera and he's
saying okay
uh this is over here this is over here
you know oh uh i got the the safety is
over here i'm gonna check down on this
play
then you let you know the uh
play-by-play guy call the play and then
you could have it reversed where tom
looks at it from the defensive side of
things if you wanted to and say uh as
the strong safety or the linebacker this
is what i i see here or i saw here and
you could almost let him be the
quarterback while he's doing his job as
the analyst thought that's a that's
definitely a good idea the thing you
will see more of i guarantee you is more
two shots uh where they come back from
commercial and they come to the booth
and you see tom brady i mean if you have
tom brady you want to see him because
that's the thing about doing games as
compared to studio you do not see the
guys calling the game so what you say in
your voice is much more important than
how you look you know on studio you're
on camera basically the whole time and
if you have a presence that's really
something that um like someone like drew
brees for example on nbc's show like
he's one of the greatest quarterbacks of
all time but he's not a big guy like
he's no presence to him on when he's on
in studio um and so when you with brady
i think he'll see him a lot on camera
they'll try to utilize that they want
you to know that tom brady is doing the
game but not hit you over the head with
it and then ultimately it's going to be
what he says and you know how he says it
if he's into it um it's going to be
fascinating we're talking andrew
marchand he had the news that tom brady
is going to fox that 10-year deal he's a
senior sports media columnist for the
new york post
you know we
we love imitation here uh the manning
cast
and it's hard to replicate that because
you got the two brothers there and their
relationship although we came pretty
close i think uh with the college
basketball diana taurasi and sue bird
that was a lot of fun there
i'm gonna
are there other shows that are looking
to try to do this manning cast this
upcoming season
well there's been other successes right
nickelodeon
with noah eagle and nate burlson uh was
really good um but you know that was
only a one-off right so they did that
they're gonna do that again this year
this year it's gonna be the regular
season um you know next week joe buck is
gonna do a buck cast on the pga
championship with michael collins uh
espn's golf uh analyst uh
so yeah people are gonna replicate it i
think you hit it on the head though and
you know this right from your again then
you know i'm talking to you are you you
know as much as i do it's not poor about
this stuff but it's the relationship
right and so when you talked about uh
taurasi and sue bird you could tell
watching that show they're good friends
it makes it easy if you could say
whatever you want and there's happens to
be a camera there what made uh peyton
and eli come alive is peyton is like you
know he's great and he's um
uh and he knows so much and he sees so
much but he's anal like he's so like
everything has to be right and then eli
is sitting there you know making jokes
and cracking on peyton and like how many
other people could do a show with peyton
manning and just crack on them all the
time where it's not like dude who do you
think you are it's like well i think
you're my i'm your brother you know i
mean i'm your little brother and i did
pretty well you know i'd be pretty twice
in the super bowl uh you know you didn't
do that um and so that's what really
made the show uh jump out but yeah
there's gonna be copycats i mean i
wouldn't overdo it and it's interesting
like the buck cast it's gonna be on main
espn for that first hour so when you put
on the pga i guess it's next thursday
that first hour is going to be the buck
castle i'm interested to see what the
reaction is when you start a broadcast
like that and it's not just on you know
an espn2 or an espn plus which is where
it will eventually move to yeah that
doesn't interest me you know it just
i i just want to watch and and if i
don't want to watch then i can go
someplace else to it but i don't know i
don't need a bunch of voices in there
i think when it's secondary it's fine
right when you have to opt in when it's
your main broadcast that's why i think
it'll be interesting to see what the
reaction is when it's the first again
you can watch the main broadcast for
espn on the pga on espn plus but you got
to work for that right you're normally
just going to put on espn and you're
going to have the bookcast
uh before i let you go formula one seems
to be the new cool sports uh
on tv younger demo
seem to kind of gobble it up
celebrities there you got beautiful
people weather cars you know it's almost
like the fast and the furious here what
do you uh what do you make of the future
of f1 here in the united states yeah
it's growing for sure now
it is growing but it's going like you
know people compare it like it's the nfl
they're going there they take a five
minute like right now i think the right
speed is like five mil or something so
you know they they might get um joe buck
money like 75 million dollars or so for
the whole you know for the year for deal
um and so um but yeah look it's it's
what they have captured i think this is
something on netflix world where you
don't have commercials a lot of people
talk about the actual netflix series but
i think it's more that you don't have
commercials you don't have excitement
they've built up the story lines um
that's what people want it's you know
it's fast and it's always moving and i
think when you look at some of these
sports in terms of watching and i'm much
higher on baseball than the rest of the
world i mean baseball's doing great
however when the games are now you know
they're three hours there's commercial
there's a lot of dead time the sports
that are going to succeed i think soccer
you know it's partly because of the tvs
are better right we have hd and then
partly soccer you're in and out in two
hours that's you know you're gonna be in
and out in two hours that's really
important um and so uh you know f1
though yeah it's definitely having a
moment i think it will continue to grow
give us the sports media story to keep
an eye on you got one
well the next one's gonna be you know
does greg olson get the fox sports uh
job which i think he will um
we had shefter and woj uh i'm trying to
think what else is coming up next and we
just had like the most you know historic
run uh with these nfl tv moves uh that
we've had you know i guess the big thing
probably for people is apple and sunday
ticket i think people are very
interested to see where that ends up
does it go to apple does it go to espn
does it go to amazon i'd say apple is
probably the favorite what is better for
our brand to win a sports emmy for this
show
or to continue to lose this would be the
fifth consecutive year
i would say to lose i mean first of all
i used to go
with uh when i was at espn i used to go
with josh cruz or not maybe that was
before anyways josh cru lewis from espn
vp i used to sit next to him and we'd
predict each um one and i'd always
predict who i thought was least
deserving to get the uh award so that
that's who i found usually one that was
my little technique to try to win so dan
that means you're most deserving okay if
you keep losing that means you're a
winner oh
okay no trophy you gotta i can send you
a program where i used to cross them off
all right i got that one you got that
one okay
uh great stuff as always andrew thanks
for joining us
thanks then it's andrew marshawn he
covers sports media for the new york
post